[Music]
hardly any mcu movie is currently being
hyped as much as spider-man no way home
the film not only marks the departure of
tom holland and his character from the
mcu but is also a real feast for fans of
the predecessors and an important
pioneer in phase 4 of the mcu we now
introduce you to a few details that make
the teaser trailer a real spoiler-free
masterpiece a good indicator to
categorize scenes are usually the
outfits of the movie characters in this
regard it is noticeable that mj wears
the same clothes as in the post-credits
scene of far from home
even the astonished face of peter parker
at the variano far from home is now
given context as in the new trailer we
get to see mj and spidey being chased
and insulted by seemingly endless crowds
of angry protesters
the motive is clear after all the whole
world now knows what the friendly
neighborhood spider's name is as well as
what he looks like various posters read
public enemy number one a campaign that
is no doubt filled by jay jonah jameson
and the daily bugle after all they are
attempting to frame spider-man for
mysterious death
what also surprised us is dr strange's
general demeanor he seems to have become
noticeable more arrogant perhaps even
joe will much like he was at the
beginning of the first doctor strange
movie
also his unquestioning willingness to
help peter against the wishes of his
friend wong seems somehow unusual
especially in relation to the wing to
peter that has been brought up several
times in memes
it was also exciting to see that there
is clear evidence of electro and sandman
you may not see either of them directly
but in one scene peter seems to be
protected by sandman from a yellow beam
from the electric bad guy the same goes
for one of the most popular villains of
the spiderman franchise the green goblin
he doesn't make a personal appearance
either but you can see an orange and
green explosive bomb rolling between a
couple of cars towards the camera
accompanied by the character's typical
maniacal laughter
needless to say the only returnee who
can actually be seen as doc ock
appearing in a spectacular fight scene
and addressing peter directly a truly
epic moment that gives you goosebumps
after a very long cinema-free period
cinemacon in las vegas is at least a
glimmer of hope again for movie fans
around the globe of course among the top
class films that will be released in the
coming year one cannot be missing the
batman med reef's standalone film has
been causing commotion since its very
early announcement in 2015 initially
mostly negative many fans were bothered
by robert patterson signing for the
leading role but in the meantime the
hype has grown bigger than ever in order
to keep the fan spirits up walnut
brothers released what is now the second
trailer for the dc spectacle besides
scenes from the movie behind the scenes
footage was also shown in las vegas as
well gotham city seems to sing the chaos
in the trailer while dramatic music
plays on the background pattinson
himself comments that the batman we will
see in the finished film will be
radically different from the previous
cinematic characters reeves also asked
that it will be an emotional movie based
on the batman year one comic by frank
miller and david mazzakelli moreover
there are fight scenes between batman
and catwoman in the trailer which have a
very personal touch also andy circus can
be seen in his role as alfred of course
in proper style with a vest and white
hair
eventually the trailer ends with a
badmobile revving up its engine and a
few porting words from director med
reeves we can't wait to see the trailer
with their own eyes and look forward to
the release of the dc blockbuster on
march 4th 2022
speculation about the title has been
going on for a long time but now with
cinemacon it was indeed confirmed that
the 4th matrix installment will carry
the title the matrix resurrections
in keeping with this there was even a
first trailer which was shown
exclusively in las vegas so we must rely
on eyewitness report our summary is
based primarily on coverage from the
outlet screenrant and the hollywood
reporter
the story is set in the san francisco of
the future and features a thomas
anderson who apparently has no memory of
the events of the past three films he's
undergoing treatment by a psychiatrist
who's played by neil patrick harris and
is diligently consuming blue pills as he
keeps seeing the matrix codes in his
surroundings
in a store neil then meets his companion
trinity whom he of course also doesn't
recognize
later a young morpheus shows up and
gives neil the red pill where pawnee
follows a strange person with a bunny
tattoo through a mirror we assume that
this is the german actor max riemold
these opening scenes are immediately
followed by hard-hitting action and good
old matrix style including martial arts
slow motion and telekinetic powers
the trailer ends with neo meeting a man
in a suit who advises him to return to
the matrix all sounds pretty exciting
though clearly the question is when will
we be able to see the trailer looking at
spider-man no way home a secret trailer
can turn into a video available to the
whole movie world in no time all
depending on the respective marketing
strategy of course
we strongly expect a prompt release
after all the film will already hit
theaters on december 22nd
be sure to activate the notification
bell on our channel because the release
is just a matter of time
cinemacon not only had a brand new
trailer for matrix 4 up its sleeve but
also fresh footage of the upcoming
jurassic world dominion
since both trailers are not yet intended
for the public we have to settle for
eyewitness reports from those present on
site and they promise a lot for the
third and final installment of the
jurassic world series
in the trailer shown by universal in las
vegas we pleasingly do not only see the
jurassic world cast around chris brett
bryce dallas howard and the likes but
also the stars of the very first
jurassic park film from 1993 namely
laura dern sam neil bidi wong as well as
jeff goldblum
more or less the story is clear because
after the dinosaurs have scattered to
all parts of the world they pose a huge
threat to humans
that's exactly what the trailer picks up
on so for example you can see chris
pratt and bryce dallas howard during a
wild chase with dinosaurs on a snowy
peak in general the trailer seems to be
full of action including giant dinosaurs
in cities and a mosasaurus rising from
the ocean and devouring an entire
helicopter the animations are said to
look stunning mostly due to really good
mix of cgi and practical effects
well all sounds very promising and we
hope to be able to show you the
full-length trailer on our channel soon
sadly we don't know when exactly that
will be at this time
jurassic world dominion will be released
in theories on june 10th 2022
last year the death of chadwick boseman
cast a cloud over the entire film world
respecting the legacy of the king's
cella actor disney decided not to recast
his role obviously no one can fill the
void he left behind nevertheless there
is an important new addition for the
sequel as marvel boss kevin feige
recently confirmed in an interview with
comicbook.com the character erie
williams aka ironheart will finally make
her mcu movie debut
in the same breath he announced that she
will be played by american actress
dominic thorne who already started
shooting her own iron heart series last
week
people like to speak out riri williams
as an iron man successor and for good
reason she is a very talented inventor
who studies at the world famous mit and
in the comics she's even supported by
tony stark himself
much like a role model she built her own
improved ironman suit and is logically
highly technically adept
speculation has it that she will first
debut as river williams in black panther
2 and then become the superhero
ironheart in the disney plus series
black panther wakanda forever will be
out in theaters starting july 8th 2022
while the ironheart series will be
released later as a result
the anime cowboy bebop has been one of
the best of its kind since its release
in 1998. all the better that fans will
finally get to see live-action adaption
on netflix starting in november after
the three-year stage of development at
least there are now images of the series
which give us a very first impression
among others john joe can be seen as
former red dragon member spike spiegel
daniela pineda as bounty hunter faye
valentine and masterful shakir as
ex-police officer jet black
another loyal member of the bebop crew
is the corki ein who can be seen next to
fey in one of the pictures the dog's
peculiarity is not only its cute
appearance but especially its extremely
high intelligence it's not for nothing
that the name iron comes from its
namesake albert einstein even though
many anime fans are traditionally
critical of live action adaptions it
needs to be said that the images shown
are quite harmonious and atmospheric
speaking of atmosphere the composer of
the original kalioku will also be adding
the final touch to the netflix series
with their jazzy and melancholic works
director watanabe shinichiro is also
coming back serving as an advisor to
producers andrei nemik and jeff pinkner
the first season of cowboy bebop will
consist of 10 episodes and will be
available on netflix from november 19
2021
the expandables movie series is
primarily known for two things badass
action and big names after three parts
so far a few weeks ago there was a
rather odd photo of sylvester stallone
with a distinctive ring of his character
now he has followed up with more
information about the sequel likewise on
social media stallone published a
photograph of her tattoo on which his
character barney ross is visible in the
image description he further informs
that filming on a spin-off will begin in
october and that it will bear the
working title of christmas story of
course this doesn't necessarily mean
that it will be christmasy in fact it's
more of a reference to the character
early christmas who will be portrayed by
jason statham
fans of brute force who may not have
gotten their money's worth in the
expandables 3 can expect a slightly
harsher a trading again in the upcoming
film
unfortunately there is neither release
date no more detailed information
regarding the content but we will of
course keep you up to date
that's it for today thanks for watching
if you want to know more about the
upcoming the matrix 4 check out our
recently published original episode
where we are talking about some crazy
story theories for the highly
anticipated sequel
see you next time
[Music]
you